nevada now has the highest number of
covet hospitalizations per capita here
in the u.s
cbs news's david becknow shows us how
the one of the hospitals up in reno
is taking drastic measures
renowned health in reno nevada services
one million people
over one hundred thousand square miles
and now the hospital
is in crisis mode look at what they have
had to resort to
they're putting patients in their
parking garage our front line caregivers
are seeing things that they never would
have imagined
anthony slanom is president and ceo of
renowned health
for him covet is personal this condition
took my father's life
he couldn't be there for him but i know
as a former icu doctor that they were
there
comforting him on the day that slaunem's
father died
the field hospital opened 265 people
have been treated here in just the last
three weeks
nobody who's gone into medicine ever
thought they would be providing care in
a parking garage
jacob keeperman is an icu doctor at
renowned health
keeperman had just moved to reno to
start working here and managing the
field hospital
when he tweeted this picture right
before it opened
some people tweeted that it was fake and
one of those tweets was retweeted
by president trump would any hospital
want to show that they are operating out
of a parking garage if it wasn't real
people's loved ones are dying every day
since march
more than 2 000 people have died in the
state of nevada from covet 19.
i have not seen anything like this for
my the time that i've been in health
care
janet baum is the field hospital's
nursing manager
never in my wildest nightmares would i
ever have thought
that we would ever see something that
would be killing this many people
the visual of people in parking stalls
is shocking to see we left reno made the
seven hour drive down to las vegas a
lonely but i will say beautiful drive to
watch the sunrise as you drive
and we made it here to las vegas coming
up on cbs this morning we will talk
about the
economic impact uh the the hurt
that covet is having on sin city so
again it is a pleasure to be here
we'll see you shortly on cbs this
morning john back to you